le cercle royal avance lentement posé
sur un affûts de canon
142 marins de la royal navy accompagne
la reine elizabeth ii les chevaux qui
étaient prévus pour tirer la plage
avaient paniqué menaçant de faire tomber
un cercueil a donc été suggérée au bout
roi edouard vii que des soldats les
remplacer voici donc à quoi ressemble
cet attelage à l'arrière le roi charles
iii sa soeur anne et ses frères puis
william l'héritier du trône et son frère
harry mise en retrait de la couronne le
cadet ne porte pas son costume militaire
nous pourrions être plus de 4 milliards
4 milliards de personnes devant nos
téléviseurs vous regardez les autres
audiences des différents événements à
chaque fois ce sont des des chiffres
totalement fou jamais autant de chefs
d'état n'ont été rassemblés ils sont 300
venus du monde entier
le président emmanuel macron est
accompagné de son épouse
tout comme son homologue américain joe
biden là les anciens premiers ministres
patrick sont en train d'avancer ensemble
dans l'abbaye de wesminster c'est une
image évidemment extrêmement forte pour
être un peu mauvaise langue quand même
parce qu'il ya une polémique sur twitter
depuis quelques heures sur emmanuel
macron qui refuse de prendre le bus avec
les autres chefs d'état j'essaie de
faire exempter notre président du voyage
en bus mais sans grand succès
certains chefs d'état qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de partager un voyage en bus
peuvent y voir une remise en cause de
leur masculinité c'est l'exception pour
joe biden le président américain arrive
dans sa propre voiture blindée vers 11h
une faveur qui lui est accordée ce
emmanuel macron qu'on va voir avec des
lunettes de soleil et en basket hier
dans les rues de londres et cette image
a été forte pour commenter et à
l'intérieur il faut être modeste
attendre humblement d'être placés que
l'on s'appelle emmanuel macron
ou joe biden le couple maquereau a fait
parler de lui pour sa tenue décontractée
dans les rues de londres voici la photo
officielle de la reine la photo choisie
pour ce jour une journée millimétré où
tout a été préparé par sa majesté
elle-même le cercueil de chêne et de
plomb et délesté de ses joyaux la
couronne impériale
le sceptre symbole du pouvoir
monarchique et se bloque d'or évoquant
le monde chrétien
[Musique]
le cercueil des sens enfin dans le
caveau royal de la chapelle dernière
image publique pour des funérailles
historiques
adrien catane ans a publié un long
communiqué hier où il reconnaît avoir
giflé son épouse le député du nord
annonce se retirer de ses fonctions de
la france insoumise dans notre dernière
dispute probablement celle qui a
justifié son choix de déposer une main
courante je les ai pris son téléphone
portable voulant le récupérer elle m'a
sauté sur le dos je me suis dégagé et en
me relâche ans elle s'est cognée le
coude la cohérence entre notre
engagement dans la lutte contre les
violences sexistes et sexuelles ne
laissait aucune place pour sa poursuite
à la tête du mouvement d'une part et
d'autre part aussi dans sa parole
publique et à partir de ce moment là il
n'y avait pas d'autre choix que adrien
14 se met en retrait ce qui a été fait
en concertation avec lui dans un
contexte d'extrême tension et
d'agressivité mutuelle j'ai donné une
gifle je les données alors que cela ne
me ressemble pas et cela ne s'est jamais
reproduit j'ai profondément regretter ce
geste et je m'en suis alors beaucoup
d'excusés il a posé les termes lui-même
bon et dans ce qui me pose ya quand même
un délit un seul chiffre c'est un délit
quelques heures après deux trois heures
jean-luc mélenchon a fait un second
tweet où il a assuré de sa sympathie les
pousses d'adrien cnas et il a dit qu'
une gifle était inacceptable moi je ne
veux pas donner de leçons de morale et
vous voyez monsieur mélenchon ils ont
ils encore raté une occasion de se taire
quand on veut avoir le nez propre il
faut il faut savoir se se moucher